industry fa faces the same difficulties
same challenges uh while while working
with cloud and Cloud um if not now but
very soon will become a commodity but
still companies are struggling to
understand to to understand what exactly
they have bought on the cloud what
exactly um they are doing right or wrong
there so this uh in the beginning we've
provided this kind of help and
Consulting through the services and then
we thought wait it's actually a global
problem it it should be this problem
will be bigger and bigger and we want to
help every company to use their Cloud
[Music]
properly vman welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for spending
these 20 minutes with me how are you
great thank you for having me here thank
you very very much for H taking this
time and how bus you are and I'm excited
to get to know your world I'm excited to
get to know um the your own journey and
what led you to a prophecy you've you've
had experience and worked in in numerous
phenomenal companies here in in the
Israel ecosystem from Microsoft to
veronis and so you know definitely a lot
of experience leading up to what you're
doing in RSA leading up to what you're
doing at prophecy today and so I am
excited to just dive in tell me a little
bit about you know what what is this
problem space that we're living in in
that you that you came to solve about
six years
ago oh great question
actually um a little bit of History um
we actually uh We've started our journey
with the uh with founding the devops uh
consultancy firm and we've done many
projects beautiful projects helped many
customers in the world of devops and
Cloud was Cloud adoption cloud
security and of course Cloud costs and
what we found that every company small
or or large um in every industry face
faces the same difficulties same
challenges uh while while working with
cloud and Cloud um if not now but very
soon will become a commodity but still
companies are struggling to understand
to to understand what exactly they have
B on the cloud what exactly um they are
doing right or wrong there so this uh in
the beginning we've provided this kind
of help and Consulting through the
services and then we thought wait it's
actually a global problem it it should
be this problem will be bigger and
bigger and we want to help every company
to use their Cloud properly so we've
founded the um startup named prophecy
labs and we've developed H yeah very
original um and we've developed a
product named Unis Sky something that
unifies all the clouds in the sky and uh
provides ability to actually enable our
customers to gain control over their
Cloud everything Cloud visibility Cloud
expenses a little bit glimpse of cloud
security but in in the recent years um
the the topic of spendings topic of
savings is uh very very important so
focused on this and uh Curr during um
past two years there is a new modern
world for this it's called phobs
combination of finance and operations so
this is exactly what we are solving
we've created a phobs operating system
unai
phenomenal and so how had you know it's
you you've been then as part of the
cloud transformation I see I see
multiple Transformations I guess in
Cloud one is the introduction of the new
technologies and the new Concepts behind
Cloud but then there's the then there
were the early adopters right so we saw
a boom in companies you know anything
from the iPhone and Facebook from the
20067 to the I guess mid
2010s and it really feels like over the
last few years there's especially
throughout covid there's a big push for
digitization across the board so you've
ran prophecy already through Co what
what has been your experience in the
last six years of the adoption of
digital and cloud and and how has that
impacted your perspective and what the
ecosystem needs
here yeah cloud is something that every
company uh needs H once you have a small
team with uh two developers you need to
uh to use some Hardware very soon uh
there will be no concept of uh of buying
Hardware anymore and we we still see
companies that we help them to migrate
from on premise to Cloud but uh in the
upcoming years it will be less and less
and what we saw so you right covid um
has a um actually served as a c Catalyst
to to this migration and still just a
funny fact H did you did you know that
currently only 15% of all possible
future Cloud users are on cloud we have
85% yet yet to to migrate so it's a huge
Market huge opportunity huge needs for
every company and our mission how we
defined it is to make
Cloud affordable and accessible for
every
company okay that's incredible so
looking at that mission making Cloud
accessible and affordable to every
company
and understanding that 85% of of
companies are not yet onboarded into the
cloud and and so obviously you know it's
a big mission why this your
mission um I think that we are said
interesting question I think that uh uh
we already um gain so much experience of
uh of doing this we know every bit and
bite of uh um how we should build well
architected infrastructure on the cloud
what are the best practices how we can
automate this how we may you know our de
devops experts only work according to
infrastructure as a code making
everything um repeatable and um and uh
built
correctly and uh we thought that it
would be a right thing to leverage our
knowledge to and to make a nice UI over
all our knowledge that we have and just
to make uh our customers to the the user
look and feel of a very easy experience
of working with a cloud one of our uh
advantages in in the Unis Sky product is
that we enable the full collaboration
between all the Departments of the
company and everybody can can use the
cloud everybody has the different end go
that he needs while they working with a
cloud and uh with our platform you don't
have to be develop certified engineer
you can be um QA engineer you can be
developer you can be manager you can be
Finance uh somebody from finance
department and uh you have your piece of
how you would you should interact with
the cloud and it should be easy it
should be
understandable yeah and and if I'm
looking it a little bit into your own
sort of your own um personal Journey so
know I'll also if you can help me tie in
your
you know the things you've done until
now at at the different organizations
from Microsoft to RSA Etc how how has
how have L they led to you becoming
excited about this space um you know
these are I'm I'm assuming that you know
you those were also bigger I'm noticing
those were bigger organizations and yet
I assume that a lot of the work that is
potentially to be done here and under
your mission is also for smaller
companies and not as necessarily just
the Giants how do you how do you see the
connection yeah yeah you know all my all
my career uh I've been somewhere in
between between technology and business
uh since the the university um you know
computer science with the business
administration and then all my life I've
managed um the process of uh software
product
development so uh I worked with uh
within great companies indeed and uh all
this experience helped me when once we
started to work in Prophecy uh help me
to leverage it to to build the right
product to build to build it in the
agile way in the way when we understand
the needs of the
customers um so yeah it's it's a big
change for me it was a big change to to
you know um the transformation from
working in as a part of a very big
company to building something very small
in the beginning uh but I think that
it's a great school for every Journey
every entrepreneurship um further so y
okay so um if you get into now the
experience that organizations have when
interacting with your platform how what
is sort of their Journey like both from
a I guess customer experience
perspective but then also from a product
perspective how how does the integration
work who do you work within the
organizations and and what is what are
the steps that you take them through the
integration uh We've uh invested lots of
thoughts in the integration and it's uh
we're really proud to say that it's very
easy it's literally three clicks and uh
If youve U re reviewed our uh ments that
we've gain on the G2 platform with
several quarters in a row we've gained
the easiest to use fops platform and
it's literally you're connecting with
three clicks then in 10 minutes you see
all your Cloud infrastructure in one
place and then it's a really role based
uh role based Journey for everybody for
example if you're somebody from Finance
team you will be interested in uh
billing and uh all the reports are
conducted to to the business needs and
if you are a devops you want to make
your job easier and uh to save manual
work and do several clicks and save
money as then you will be uh starring in
these reports in the finance team so we
are actually connected all the
connecting all the dots inside the
organization in small organizations we
usually work with a few small amount
of stakeholders in large organizations
it can be many groups that are involved
and every user has this their own role
and your own permission and uh together
they they're able to communicate through
our
platform phenomenal and um I think
obviously when when looking at the
ambition of enabling smooth smooth work
with cloud and either where whether it's
to transform into the cloud or or
optimizing on the cloud there's
different aha moments or moments of you
know Delight I guess for the customer
how what are those moments for
you um our platform covers all the
possible um possible best practices of
phobs we actually automate every piece
of phobs so we see these aha moments uh
for every customer in different places
it's very funny sometimes um customer
sees our first dashboard with a map of
all the regions where he has has the the
resources and he says wait why I have
something in Australia I didn't bought
anything in Australia let me show me
show me please show and let's remove it
and uh sometimes it's a um if we're
talking about customers who invested
already heavily in all these analytics
and working with on cloud expenses and
savings then uh Thea moment is uh is
very satisfying for us because they're
looking and they choosing many options
and then suddenly they say wait this is
not something that we have yet H let's
see it so it's a combination and
actually it's a function of uh how um
what the customer already did with their
Cloud before they started to work with
Unis sky and and it's a little bit like
like a uh like houskeeping you know if
uh if you if you invest in this uh
manually and then uh you uh you bringing
help into the house you you it depends
um if you see the impact on how it was
before the house housekeeper started to
to help you I think that's that's really
really interesting I I have two two
questions that that I'm that I'd love to
get pick your brain on and there's a
sentence that in the on your LinkedIn
tagline that that I think is is Raising
interesting questions on on on the
decision-making level of of how of the
positioning of of the organization um
the first sentence read Israeli devops
and Cloud Boutique
company and so
um tell talk to me a little bit about
the isra why why is that the first word
on the tagline
here ER uh it was uh it was our
historical uh tagline uh since then um
many things were involved and uh and uh
uh We've uh um we've started to um to
recruit people from uh uh from not from
Israel not only from Israel and
currently we have a a site of uh devops
Engineers developers most of our
employees are not Israeli they um uh
their roots are are in Ukraine and most
of the
employees H so now we are presenting
ourself as Israeli Ukrainian company uh
specifically in these days it's a very
you know when the war started on the on
October 7th uh we gain such a great
support from our um our team and team
members and partners uh from abroad and
uh especially guys from Ukraine who
share their experience yeah I'm sure
same yeah it's a it's not funny it's
very uh not normal situation but uh I I
I can only imagine and and regardless I
think that it's still you know it gives
it for me it gave also a feeling this is
a place that that you know really cares
about the you know it's a it's a it's a
cloud company it's a high it's
technology company yet when you start
even even if it's a you know a tagine of
History starting the sentence with a
little bit about who you are I think
that puts a little bit of light into
perhaps the culture and a little bit of
how you how you see yourself sort of on
the people side
is the word Boutique still relevant here
yes I think that even when we will have
uh thousand team members it will still
be relevant because it's part of our DNA
this is what um distinguishes us from
from other companies in the same area
and our uh uh culture is to provide for
every customer Boutique solution
something that is tailored specifically
for the
customer and um doesn't matter how how
big we will become uh we will still keep
still keep uh working according to this
principle because I think that uh this
is a um this is something that is really
missing in u the whole concept of SAS of
uh of
service um mindset and it's very
important for our
customers 100% so looking back at these
past six years what is what have been
some of the most I guess um exhilarating
or or amazing moments for you as an
entrepreneur I think that were there
were lots of such a moments we our um um
our first recruitments our uh um the
money that uh um SE the round that we
raised and uh the Boost that came after
it first paying customers first largest
customers uh every I remember the when
the first large Bank uh became our
customer uh our uh sales uh executive
called us uh saying um they're
connecting all their accounts let's
let's hold this platform and we said you
know the platform is fine let's let's
see what what happens and uh many
exciting moments and until now we are uh
currently uh many new customers are uh
going on board um even though the
situation in Israel specifically and in
the world you know the overall situation
um many new projects are um on boarded
every project every customer is an
excitement phenomenal if you have to see
where this is going to be in several
years what's your vision for
prophecy uh we want to be um an
ultimative uh platform operating system
for uh people who are working with Cloud
uh we want to to become company that is
um uh you know like uh there are several
brands that uh um the name of the brand
became uh became a concept of this
product like Jeep or even though it's
only one uh one of the companies so want
to become uh this kind of product uh in
PHS World in Cloud management
world no no Vera I really want to thank
you for taking the time I love how
you're looking at um f first it sounds
like you're you're very excited about
the opportunity of of what you're doing
and I didn't realize that 85% of cloud
of companies aren't yet in the cloud um
but also the mission of making Cloud
affordable and accessible to every
company and I think that's a it's a
wonderful Mission and uh and it sounds
uh it was just a great conversation and
thank you so much for for team Ty to
share this with me all the way to the
boutique culture of making sure that
every customer feels like you're
tailoring the experience to them and the
solution to them so thank you very very
much wishing you best of luck
thank you so much you
[Music]